cinema history is full of dazzling
technical achievements and masterful
editing but some of the most impressive
sequences of all time are shot in one
long fluid take actors and crew members
practice the elaborate sequence until
it's second nature rehearsing every line
in every camera movement until they're
able to execute a gorgeous sequence in a
single unbroken shot here are a few of
the best examples of the form Goodfellas
the films of Martin Scorsese are
absolutely loaded with iconic shots but
few are as well remembered as this
gorgeous long take from Goodfellas known
as the Copa shot it's a nearly
three-minute Steadicam take that follows
Henry and Karen as they enter the
Copacabana nightclub through side
entrance so Henry can flaunt his many
mob base connections
according to camera operator Larry
McConkey the shot was originally just a
simple case of the camera following the
actors but he and cinematographer
Michael Ball Haas decided to spice up
the blocking they did this in part
because McConkey needed pauses in the
walk so he could transition between wide
shots and close-ups without cutting away
that's why they added touches like a
walk through the club's kitchen in the
moment when Henry stops to playfully
chastise a flirting couple Creed nearly
40 years after the first rocky film the
franchise revitalizer Creed delivered a
dazzling uninterrupted fight sequence
for the fight between Adonis and Leo the
Lion spirito director Ryan Coogler
wanted to achieve the visual metaphor of
the two boxers being suddenly all on
their own after months of working with
their trainers so the fight was filmed
as one continuous Steadicam take with
the camera dancing around the actors
Kubler shot 13 takes of the fight with
no additional cameras on set to provide
extra coverage should he later decide to
break it up in the editing room
the result is an intense intimate
sequence that ranks among the best
moments in boxing cinema since
Scorsese's Raging Bull Children of Men
the acclaimed four-minute car attack
scene in 2006 as children of men was
shot with a special rig that not only
allowed the camera to move around within
the cramped car but move out of it later
there are a lot of moving parts in this
scene to make things even more stressful
director Alfonso Cuaron revealed during
a 2013 San Diego comic-con panel that he
only had approximately four takes
available to get the shot right it ended
up coming down
the very last take before the production
was going to lose access to the location
and korone almost ruined that one
himself we were shooting the last take
everything goes great but then by
accident the blood spills onto the lens
I yelled cut but there was an explosion
and nobody heard me so they kept
shooting then later I realized that the
blood splash was the miracle the final
take the one for own almost a banded mid
shot is the one in the film the player
Robert Altman was one of the most
famously playful directors of the 20th
century the player a dark satire about a
ruthless Hollywood executive is
essentially a movie about movies so
Altman took every chance possible to
cram in references to classic films he
also took the opportunity to give us the
entire look and feel of the film in an
unbroken eight-minute opening shot
beginning with the tongue-in-cheek
clicking of a film slate the tape pulls
back and rises up into a wide crane shot
in an homage to Orson Welles as Touch of
Evil
then the camera dances around the lot
following various characters and nodding
to several cinema classics even if
you're a true movie buff it'll take you
a few tries to catch every reference and
inside joke in the uncut sequence must
be crazy except the coke bottles now
television actress exactly right it's
out of Africa meets pretty woman the
protector though the final product often
looks amazing shooting heavily edited
fight scenes like this taken three
sequence can be tedious work with tons
of close-ups of hands feet and faces or
you can do with creators of 2005's tie
action classic the protector did shoot a
badass 4-minute fight scene featuring
one hero one camera dozens of stuntmen
and lots of stairs in a single amazing
take in this sequence the hero has made
his way to a restaurant specializing in
exotic meats where he believes a
gangster is holding his beloved
elephants proving just how far one man
will go for his animal friends Tom
storms the restaurants VIP area where
he's confronted by an enormous spiral
staircase and a load of henchmen ready
to take him out the result is one of the
best fight sequences of the past two
decades plus it has arguably the best
action hero closing line in the history
of cinema
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]